stephen hawking soll kurz vor seinem tod
noch ein geniestreich gelungen seien der
beweis von paralleluniversum der beweis
der existenz eines multiversums einer
welt von der universum das wäre wirklich
eine unglaubliche situation es gibt
nämlich zahlreiche modelle hypothesen
und theorien über die existenz von
parallel universen aber keine einzige
davon konnte auch nur im ansatz bewiesen
werden das könnte jetzt auf einen schlag
anders werden und stephen hawking würde
auf einen schlag in die absolut erste
reihe der physiker aufsteigen
was ist also mit dem multiversum auf
sich hat und was stephen hawking
bewiesen hat jetzt den krieg zum science
fiction
das wäre wirklich eine absolute hammer
stephen hawking würde seinem lebenswerk
die krone aufsetzen und die physik welt
umkrempeln eine welt aus parallel
universen ein multiversum aber was
könnte er bewiesen haben für ein
multiversum gibt es verschiedene ansätze
der eine ansatz ist der der
heisenbergsche unschärferelation wellen
neben ja erst ihre teilchen
eigenschaften an wenn sie beobachtet
wenn sie gemessen werden spricht werden
sie nicht beobachtet gibt es
wahrscheinlichkeiten mit dem sie an
bestimmten orten existieren
sie existieren aber nicht dort man
könnte auch sagen dass sie nicht
existieren da ja nicht festgestellt
werden kann wo sie sind oder in welchem
zustand sie sind bundes beispiel das
doppel spalt experiment lasse ich nicht
durch einen doppel spalt fallen bildet
es als projektion ein interferenzmuster
messe ich aber durch welchen spalt
welches lichtzeichen fliegt ändert das
licht seine eigenschaft von einem
interferenzmuster verursachten welle
teilchen das interferenzmuster
verschwindet die beiden spalte werden
jetzt projiziert oder schuldiger das
berühmte katze lasse ich eine katze
sterben wenn ein bestimmtes teilchen
zerfällt dann stürzt sie nicht bzw
sie stirbt oder sich stirbt eben auch
nicht und zwar erst wenn wir den zustand
des teilchens messen vorher gab es nur
eine wahrscheinlichkeit des verfalls und
das ist tatsächlich so die katze war
damit auch nur mit einer
wahrscheinlichkeit tot oder lebendig
total verrückt daher stammt aber die
theorie dass sich die welt erst in dem
moment manifestiert in der wir sie
messen oder beobachten vorher sind es
nur wellen und wahrscheinlichkeiten wir
würden dann jeweils durch messen und
beobachten immer wieder neue universen
entstehen lassen das ist komplett
verrückt wirklich ein anderer ansatz
wäre die stringtheorie sie besagt dass
alles nur wählen sind also sehr ähnlich
eine meiner lieblings theorien alles
besteht aus einen dimensionalen fäden
linien die in einer bestimmten frequenz
oder einem bestimmten frequenzbereich
schwingen bei licht können wir das ja
ganz gut nachvollziehen
demnach nach dieser theorie gibt es noch
zahlreiche weitere dimensionen und in
diesen dimensionen existieren dann
parallel universum und sie können sogar
miteinander kollidieren über eine spur
einer solchen kollision hatte ich ja
hier letztlich berichtet alles in allem
ist aber keine der theorien bewiesen
das sind letztlich im gegensatz zum
bewies
klimawandel oder der zweifelsfrei
bewiesen evolutionstheorie nur
denkmodelle oder gedankenexperimente
wenn man allerdings diese modelle oder
eines dieser modelle mit einem
mathematischen konstrukt beschreiben
kann und dann noch einen beweis daraus
herleiten kann dann wird es eine theorie
die bewiesen ist allerdings dürfen das
dann nicht nur entwickler dieser theorie
und dieses beweises machen sondern auch
andere wissenschaftler müssen in der
lage sein das durchzurechnen und zu
beweisen dann wird eine solche theorie
zur bewiesene theorie und wir haben eine
wirkliche erkenntnisse gewonnen hawking
hat für viele grundlegende phänomene wie
schwarze löcher den urknall den
ereignishorizont von schwarzen löchern
das schon oft getan und jetzt kommt
vielleicht sein meisterwerk gemeinsam
mit dem belgischen physiker thomas
hartung hat er eine multiversum theorie
entwickelt den beiden physikern sollte
es tatsächlich gelungen sein eine
mathematische grundlage für das
multiversum entwickelt zu haben sonst
wird die arbeit eben peer review
verfahren gecheckt kommen die
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
zu dem ergebnis dass die arbeit korrekt
ist wäre damit eine wissenschaftliche
bombe geplatzt ist wäre bewiesen dass
wir in einem parallel universum leben
das nächste ziel wäre zu erkunden wie
wir solche parallel universen beobachten
können oder spuren von ihnen finden
können wenn ihr kein video zu diesem
thema zum thema paralleluniversum und zu
allen anderen themen verpassen wollten
dann endet meine telefonnummer
bei whatsapp das geht ganz einfach mit
diesem link dann informiere ich über
meinen neuesten videos vor allen anderen
und das garantiert anders als sie auf
youtube dort könnte ja auch bei klick
zum mitmachen und mit themen vorschlagen
oder bei abstimmung mitmachen und damit
beeinflussen was sie auf klicks und
passiert vergessen natürlich nicht das
abo und den klick auf die genau locker
und hier geht es weiter dafür auch
draufklicken zusammenstoß mit einem
paralleluniversum
ja das ist ein spannendes thema an sonst
würde ich mal sagen bis dann bleibt dran